now there's no way you can
build up your bones okay if you have
osteoporosis with calcium
it's not going to happen what's going to
happen if you attempt to do that is
you're going to get calcification of
your arteries so in this video I'm going
to show you
some insights on osteoporosis as well as
osteopenia what is osteoporosis
osteoporosis is a loss of bone density
and bone mass and so the problem with
that is you're at risk for a fracture
now the purpose of bone is to give you
structure
to have a place where ligaments can
attach and it's also a reserve for
minerals so if you need more calcium or
phosphorus bone is that Reserve and so
many people just focus on the calcium
aspect of bone but phosphorus like 85
percent of phosphorus is stored in your
bone yet we ignore phosphorus and the
thing you need to know about phosphorus
is that you can have problems with your
bone if you have uh too little
phosphorus or too much because if you
have too much phosphorus as in if you
drink a lot of sodas or things with
phosphoric acid or junk foods that can
cause bone loss as well but just so you
know phosphorus is in a lot of foods
it's in Meats fish eggs it's even in
Dairy it's in vegetables so most people
have enough phosphorus unless they're
doing things to deplete phosphorus like
I said consuming junk Foods or drinking
the sodas or they have a kidney problem
or they're taking certain medications
that are interfering with phosphorus
osteoporosis is severe bone loss putting
you at risk for fractures osteopenia is
kind of a subclinical or a stage that
comes before Osteo porosis and what's
interesting about osteopenia is over 50
percent of women over the age of 50 have
some degree of osteopenia and a
significant amount of men have it as
well but osteopenio doesn't really put
you at risk for fractures it's just a
good indicator that you know you're
going down a road that you could end up
with osteoporosis but typically a lot of
people are totally on here take these
medications exercise maybe you should
start chewing those chocolate calcium
bone building things which are just a
joke but there's a paradox involved with
calcification what they found with this
Paradox is that uh people that have
osteoporosis have a much higher degree
of calcification in the arteries and the
adjoints so that's kind of weird that
you're having all this excess calcium
but it's not going in the right place
the other point I want to bring up about
bone is that in the bone marrow you have
an entire Factory that is making blood
red blood cells white blood cells and
platelets so bone is composed of
not just calcium a lot of minerals also
35 percent of bone is protein mostly in
the form of collagen so let's go through
the key nutrients that are needed to
either reverse osteopenia and
osteoporosis and even another thing
called osteomalacia let me just tell you
what that is osteomalacia is kind of
soft bones in adults and that is
primarily from a vitamin D deficiency
when this occurs in children we call
that rickets when we're dealing with
osteoporosis or osteopenia we're not
just looking at a loss of calcium we're
looking at a vitamin K2 deficiency a
vitamin D3 deficiency usually which
works with K2 together so let's just
start out with vitamin K2 vitamin K2 is
a fairly recently discovered
vitamin it's a fat soluble vitamin comes
from fatty foods
it also can come from fermented foods in
Asia they have something called NATO
which is fermented soybeans and that is
very high in vitamin K2 vitamin K2 is
also in raw sauerkraut but mainly it's
in like a fatty sausage it's in fatty
cheese it's even an egg yolks it's in
liver and so what you need to know about
that is that if you're on a low fat diet
or you're taking certain medications
that block vitamin K2 like statins if
you're on a blood thinner or even
antidepressants antacids certain
medications for high blood pressure or
even medications for erectile
dysfunction you're not going to get
enough of vitamin K2 so vitamin K2 is
really really important if not the most
important
vitamin for making your bones really
really solid and hard but you also need
Vitamin D3 with it and vitamin D3 helps
the absorption of calcium by a factor of
20x in the small intestine and so
vitamin D helps absorb calcium into the
blood from the digestive system and then
vitamin K2 takes it from that blood and
drives it into the bone so it's really
important to understand what K2 does and
to make sure either you get it in your
diet or you're taking it as a supplement
if you're taking it as a supplement I
recommend the form that's called MK 7
okay versus other forms like MK4 mk7 is
a natural form and it lasts about 48
times longer in your body versus the
half-life of MK4 with about 20 000 IUS
of vitamin D3 now another key vitamin
for bone is vitamin A vitamin A and I'm
not talking about the precursor
beta-carotene retinol which is the
bioavailable true form of vitamin A is
really high in egg yolks this is why
eggs are just so important in many
different ways in your diet but
especially to get enough vitamin A
vitamin A is not just going to help you
build bone but it's also going to
prevent some of the toxicities that
potentially could occur from vitamin D
even though those would be very rare I
don't recommend getting your vitamin A
from a supplement just get it from your
food egg yolks liver or other organ
Meats vitamin A is in cheese also in
butter and cod liver oil as well and so
vitamin D3 K2 and a are all fat soluble
vitamins so another thing to look out
for or or understand is that you need a
good gallbladder and a good liver to
produce the bile to absorb these
nutrients so if you had your gallbladder
out or you have some type of problem
with your liver as in you know fatty
liver these reasons could be why you're
not getting these nutrients in which
case you should probably just take some
bile salts to help with the absorption
so we have to make sure that we're
getting these nutrients from the diet we
have to make sure that nothing's
countering those vitamins we have to
make sure we absorb them with the right
things like the bile salts but we also
have other things that help build your
bone like minerals yes I would be taking
some form of calcium if I had
osteoporosis or osteopenia but not as a
standalone I would make sure we take all
these other things as well but I would
not take the form of calcium that is not
very bioavailable and that's calcium
carbonate and so many people are taking
this type basically it's like Limestone
you'd be better off chewing on the
cement outside your house because that's
really what it is it's just the the form
of calcium that's has to go through like
12 different biochemical steps before it
gets absorbed in your body and if you're
getting older you may find that you
don't have enough stomach acid to absorb
this calcium so that's another barrier
if you don't have the acid in the
stomach okay you're not going to be able
to absorb the calcium magnesium
phosphorus and the trace minerals that
I'm going to talk about next and so the
way you would know that you wouldn't
have enough stomach acid is usually you
have indigestion bloating or acid reflux
so the type of calcium I would take is
like a calcium magnesium supplement but
try to get your calcium mostly from food
Dairy sardines
uh deep leafy green vegetables all have
a good amount of calcium and magnesium
and magnesium helps activate vitamin D
also potassium is really important too
so you can get your magnesium and
potassium from leafy greens like large
salads now as far as the trace minerals
zinc copper and Boron are the top trace
minerals but there's other ones too so
if you were to take like a a trace
mineral complex that would be the best
thing with emphasis with the zinc Boron
and the copper
these can activate certain proteins in
bone so those are really really
important as well
and Boron helps you balance out the
calcium and magnesium it just helps you
absorb those two minerals as well as the
activators of the proteins that help you
form bones since 35 percent of bone is
protein and of course when we talk about
protein make sure you have the best
biovaluable type of protein and that
would be animal proteins eggs are the
top protein and then you have fish
shellfish would be really really
important oysters clams shrimp are
really good because that will not only
give you high quality protein but the
trace minerals as well but you might be
saying what about all the cholesterol
well guess what bile salts are made out
of cholesterol and you need cholesterol
to make bile cells to help you absorb
these fat soluble nutrients and you also
need cholesterol to help build
hormones sex hormones specifically
estrogen it's not very surprising that
many women after menopause end up with
their bones becoming osteoporotic and
that has to do with this sudden drop or
shift in this estrogen dropping down so
how do you build that back up well make
sure you have all the precursors to
making these hormones and that would be
like cholesterol so as you approach
menopause you want to increase more
cholesterol okay and cholesterol does
not come from plant Foods it comes from
animal Foods eggs butter Meats things
like that and if you complement those
foods with a large salad or vegetables
each day it can really help you regulate
and moderate the amount of cholesterol
going through the body not that you're
concerned with that or not but I think
the balance of both of those type of
foods plant-based and animal based are
really important exercise would be an
important thing to add into this program
to stimulate the bone growth which will
also indirectly reduce stress because
cortisol is very destructive on your
bones so if you're going through chronic
stress that could be another reason
on top of the menopause situation where
the adrenals have to back up your
ovaries that could be a big trigger for
osteopenia than osteoporosis the other
thing you need to know about
osteoporosis is that that's a pretty
severe situation and it's going to take
a good amount of time to
fix this problem and it could take
actually up to six years of healthy
eating but I wanted to give you this
background information so you have all
the different pieces to this puzzle
what's very interesting too about
medication for osteoporosis is that some
of these medications real popular
medications increase the risk for
fractures which we're trying to avoid
now since we emphasize probably the most
important uh piece of this puzzle which
is K2 there's some additional
information that you should know about
that and I put that video up right here
check it out